I think it's the 30th anniversary of
dead no in societies yeah 30 years I'm
telling you we started shooting it was
fall of 1988 and so it's 30 years ago
and I can't believe first of all if you
had told me then the 30 years from now
people would still be asking me yeah
about it yeah I wouldn't have believed
love that one of the things I heard
about I don't know if it's true but
maybe you can clear it up Robin Williams
of course in that movie and obviously
the great Robin Williams loved to clown
around on the set and people loved him
to clown around the set but as a young
actor just starting out you didn't like
that did you look at man I was a very
serious young kid right yeah I was
you're a serious young actor I had read
my Stanislavski book I had what was in
my pockets I was working so hard to be
Todd Anderson Yeah right to be this kid
and be this character and Robin wouldn't
the more serious I was the more he like
he did to me and some would make fun of
my air get he would get the whole yeah
and you're a comedian you know this
right though yeah men you know what it
is it's night tonight yeah but you know
Robin didn't yes yes okay well Robin had
this thing if one person in the audience
didn't laugh at his new joke he went
right to that person yeah you know and
start doing jokes and I did not want to
laugh I was not going to allow to stay
in character I wanted us and so he was
merciless
to me making fun of me call me a wet rag
Oh Oh mr. Hogg doesn't think it's funny
and he was like bow down I'm like I'm
just trying to leave me alone yeah and I
really thought he hated me and then all
the guys they would just pal around and
they'd have so much fun yeah he didn't
seem that like me at all and then the
movie ended and I got this call and said
um hey I'm Robin Williams agent and he
says that you're really good and that
you need an agent and so Robin helped me
get my very first agent who I see was
having a lovely guy a lovely guy and he
hooked me up it's very nice
you
you